absolutely absolutely I'm when I was
when I was you know I started like I
said professionally cooking at 15 and I
don't know why my parents let me do it
but I was working 60 hours a week plus
going to high school and I just loved it
and I think the reason why you know they
knew I was safe I wasn't out in the
streets I was spending time in a kitchen
you know working I loved it and I I
think it was a you know it's it's
interesting because they really made me
focus on a it was a goal you know there
was a camaraderie in the kitchen that
I'd never really kind of found elsewhere
and I think when you're young and kind
of impressionable like that those are
positive influences and I and I think is
you even if you choose to go to culinary
school afterwards you know that that
doesn't mean you're prepared and ready
to take on chef them so to speak you
know there's more there's a different
level of apprenticeship that goes that
goes into it afterwards or so it seems
yeah but it is very important in
anything when you apply yourself and you
know focus on it I think that's the
important the important thing whether it
be school or apprenticeship and if you
could do both that's even better